Chris Hanes kind enough to join us he
covers the Warriors primarily these days
he was former cabs beat writer for the
Cleveland Plain Dealer the ESPN NBA
reporter joins us Chris good morning
thanks for joining us
JP thanks for having me six to 220
all right where do you want to start you
want to start with the drama in
Cleveland and how bad is this going to
get I definitely think I think what it
boils down to in collegian is that it's
all about personnel right now I know
people within our organization and
players particularly feel that you know
they didn't get the right compensation
for training Kyrie Irving and I think
most people feel that they didn't have
to go and make that move it was kind of
a Russian panic decision based off of
Kyrie warning warning out and this is
the roster that they're stuck with
because of that and and I think a lot of
people knew initially that Wendy Wendy
Way came aboard
Isaiah Derrick Rose you had a bunch of
just the talent that on paper looked
like it just wasn't going to blend well
they had their stretches but obviously I
think we're seeing the product of that
roster just not being cohesive enough to
get it done and and now you got
finger-pointing coming from everywhere
and you know it's a mess it's it's more
of a mess that I've experienced when I
was covering that change from day to day
it's gonna be really difficult for them
to get out of this one but Chris I'm
trying to understand LeBron's role
because LeBron has a roster that he
wanted here right he brought in his
friends he got guys who got max deals to
be able to stay D Wade's there he
reached out to Kevin Love to bring him
in Tristan Thompson Jerry Smith got paid
you know Korver comes in and now I don't
know if he wanted Kyrie out of town but
I feel like if he wanted Kyrie to stay
that he could have said hey I'll
convince him and turn more of the team
over to him i I don't know his role in
all of this it just feels like now all
of a sudden Kevin loves getting called
out because he maybe wasn't sick enough
to leave the building over the weekend
in the lost Oklahoma City like this is
really petty stuff going on right
what have you been experiencing in cover
LeBron over the last three four years
even beyond that it's always been pity
but why does it become penny is it him I
mean we're talking about LeBron who you
know goes out on home tweaks and you
know and tweets that players and not
directly calling them out for everybody
you know know who he's talking about and
who he's referring to so this is
something that you know everybody's
accustomed to I think what's happening
is that there's there's finger-pointing
at master you know ass in a mat in the
massive rate there are so many different
personalities on this team now it was
not just the pride look yes LeBron has a
lot to do with why they're in this
position you know personality can't
dispute that at all but you know at the
end of the day I know you want to call
the Brawn the GM and the owner but you
know he he doesn't he doesn't have to
make the calls he doesn't have to you
know call the shots and particularly
with LeBron being in his final year and
has been given ownership or management
any indication of what he's going to do
beyond the season it's up to management
and ownership to do what's best for the
franchise and look and I I don't know
what they they think that LeBron is not
going to leave or if you're gonna stay
but they have a job to protect their
team and as of right now it seems like
they've tried to cater to LeBron as much
as possible but would you trade that
hair would you trade would you try to
get DeAndre Jordan I mean getting George
Hill is a nice now wouldn't you would
not I would I wouldn't DP because like I
still don't think the odds resort and
put put them in a conversation to be
competitive with the Golden State
Warriors I don't and then you bring
DeAndre Jordan to say say look check
this out bring it DeAndre Jordan is not
going to make up LeBron James is mine on
if he's gonna return and win win or lose
I just don't think so
and so you got
the way that life if we're talking about
bringing in if they were bringing in D
way five years ago
then okay yeah maybe after LeBron says
okay they're doing all y'all attention
you know make this team competitive but
I don't think that you know I don't
think that Sister Sister tie at all so I
don't think you've got I don't think you
do that good LeBron has proven that he's
willing to do something that everybody
feels is unnecessary he's willing to do
whatever he think makes him happy
regardless of what people think and I
think it would be very foolish and very
unwise for them to trade that pick no
one what happened in in recent history
is fast yeah it just feels like if they
don't make a move then what what are
they saying about LeBron or to LeBron
and if they do make a move what are they
saying about LeBron or to LeBron look I
think I think the Cavaliers really have
to think look we have do you think
you'll be gone Chris do you think LeBron
is where is LeBron next year I don't
think he's in Cleveland where is he I
don't I don't you know I don't think la
is the number one option like most
people are very vacant yeah I wouldn't
be surprised
I think Houston via a player yeah I
think possibly San Antonio could make
something happen to where they can get
into the mix but I can't see them boom I
can't see them return to clean I feel
that way but DP if I feel that way
management ownership should have some
type of obsess Intel about that and
that's why I don't think they should go
all in and try to trade that first-round
pick it's just too risky put the
franchise in jeopardy moving forward you
cover the Warriors we're talking to
Chris Haynes ESPN NBA reporter you
covered the Warriors primarily these
days are they concerned are they curious
what's going on with Cleveland do they
even care about all of this
hell no it's funny cuz when I was
covering the Cavs and it was fun it is a
blast covering a castle abroad they all
he brought keeps you on your toes but
you know we used to go into the we were
going to locker room this one the
Warriors were you know going into their
serves know Britain reaching pinnacle
reach reach the pinnacle status and
after the game the Cavaliers will have
the Warriors games on in a locker room
and then you know this continued on its
continued on for a while and then worse
or getting out I guess we started
writing about it or talking about it and
then sooner or later they they would go
in the the TV wouldn't be on at all or
or that season would be on some obscure
game like the Utah Jazz like the players
like yeah we like that they're like the
Warriors like everybody someone make a
big deal about the the rock is now being
the the face the favors to you know give
them a fight no postseason the ghost a
Wars dismissing that knows you know they
have no worries at all that's the
difference man if they just go about
things a little bit differently the war
is - it is like hey if for me we'll see
it again but now they're not overly
concerned or looking over seeing what's
going on I think they know what's going
on I won one player told me look
Kairi ain't over there they're not
afraid there you go okay who is the leak
here how do you have this dress you know
Kevin Love gets called out and all of a
sudden next thing you know it's being
reported by woge on the mothership like
how does this stuff get from there to
there that quickly you got what about 15
people who were in about 50 is LeBron
the source Chris is LeBron this or no I
don't know that but see please let me
say this you got about 15 16 people in
that meeting and it is about 13
different people represent all those
people and so it's not I mean there's a
lot of people that it could have been
and so I I don't know I don't know but
everything leaks from Cleveland so I
can't change the roster though Chris
there's only a couple of guys that have
stayed there I don't think it was a
broad in this case but I there Thomas
you know idea Thomas was the main one
call it out Kevin Love I just like it
can come from anywhere
all right all right ain't good to talk
to you Chris
safe travels thanks for joining us I
hate it oh my god you cook here hi and
it's Chris Haynes ESPN NBA reporter for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]